okay hello everyone we are here for a
wolf language design review this is part
of the first review I think in our 13-3
uh version series and today we are
looking at sound and vision
so
uh videos
the new feature of the last year or so
um
okay so tour video updated to support
Geographics dude you're going to show me
examples of these things or how what
should we do to to get to those if you
open the ref page
um there is updated syntax and
I I believe it at least one example
make sure you're up to date Stephen when
you the source
at least in case you change things
today uh okay
so manipulate video wow
show version of manipulate to video
this is going to be a little bit more of
a discussion it's not fully cooked yet
I'll tell you the background story to it
which I think is really compelling huh
which is that
um
we can easily do basically keyframe
animations from our manipulates
if you create basically key parameter
values if you like
and then you interpolate between them
there's some error with the update here
let me just turn that in
um
okay keep going sorry
so key keyframes yeah
so then you can animate between those
and we can make it really behave you
know even if something takes time when
you generate video you can make it you
know really spiffy
but you can also create a story
because often if you use a complex
manipulate there are many experiments
that you can derive from one manipulate
that has a story okay hold up let's look
at this Geo uh tour thing first okay
I'm sorry where is the example if you
scroll down
um in scope
that there there was a tentative example
you just passed it
and that that video should be on the
cloud if you click on it
no I'm more interested in seeing it
actually run
you know I hope we're fixing this
geostyle thing that's a
it's you
okay this the geostyle again that please
whoever's pming will you please take
that to that's Jose and team I assume
that they're continuing to improve that
for 15-3 but can you please
poke them on that
basically waiting
I'm still waiting okay
all right
well we'll see what this does but now
manipulate video
it's a very weird name it's a very very
weird name
I wish that was a better way of saying
that that didn't wasn't totally
confusing with the verb noun form right
I I agree I haven't heard about that in
the
um tentative ref page
but so
this is
I mean really it's a manipulate keyframe
video is that true yeah
or it's a keyframe video derived from a
manipulate correct yes yes the point is
that we'll make many kinds of keyframe
videos we I mean the one that you're
doing right now tour video is such a
thing
is it I mean yes
okay but once you specify two key frames
one center around Paris one center
around London right but the
interpolation uh
I I see so so the manipulate okay let's
let's see this run
could I have told it to be cyclic
go back to Paris
yeah
yeah you could add another position
there Paris London Paris I see okay fine
this is pretty cool
it's pretty cool
so this is in a sense an alternative to
a manipulate as I move the video around
correct
in this case
with guaranteed performance because
there's no compute
right
and so if
if you have something very heavy duty
um that's that's compelling
right but but the other thing that I you
know what I think hold on I just want to
make another point I mean so this is
always a one parameter thing because
time in the video is one parameter
correct you've always had to but but for
example a one parameter manipulate in
the cloud
could in principle be done this way
correct
so it has no server transaction at that
point or or at least well you know it's
a very well optimized server transaction
but you know us whatever a streaming
type video
actually I don't really know because I
mean streaming videos often do all kinds
of crazy buffering you often see a lot
of buffering happening
but at least there is no computation as
Roger pointed at
if there is any expensive computation
that's done once
right
okay all right so
um go ahead Roger you were going to say
something sorry
yeah so I think that this is for
ourselves for for many of our you
unfortunately the manipulate video is
not fully cooked but let me continue to
tell the story because I think we have a
bunch of other things that affect you
and the rest of the company
I think that one of the things that we
can do is to re-energize the
demonstrations project
from this so for instance we can Engage
The contributors to really tell a story
you know so right now we have fixed
screenshot and we have this kind of
slightly stupid auto generation where it
just twiddles all controls which is not
usually correspond to any kind of
experiment that you want to do
but but let's say that you go back and
you tell a story you show these sort of
like the key experiments that this
manipulate can show or some some of it
yeah you could do a three voiceover or
you could do it with
you know yes
and so I kind of you know that's that's
interesting for demonstrations and
re-energizing that story to start to
produce shorts that for instance can go
out on you know like YouTube shorts or
other short form video like tweets
right and so I kind of think that like
like for many of our areas we we do want
to produce these videos because they can
give you kind of like a summary of
something
um like like in many cases you spend the
government spend like say a hundred
million dollars for a decent
supercomputer maybe 200 million these
days
and then what is the deliverable that
comes out it's usually a video
a short form video
you know from a simulation
um but I think we can do these things
you know our own you know like our users
and at least the more compelling
learning material more compelling
yeah
all around
but as I said I don't think manipulate
videos cooked yet to that level
but but I think that that that's the
potential
right hold on one second
and so one of the things that we've done
now is gone back most people did to to
kind of look at bookmarks because there
was something there already although
when we sampled people
turns out that 90 doesn't seem to know
about the bookmarks and manipulate
um yeah they were not widely used I mean
but but my question is
okay
so let's say we've got a demonstration
and we want to make a video out of it
and so you know
to say in modern times with the whole
alarm business and so on
maybe there are different ways to think
about how to set the bookmarks
because I I don't think I mean you know
the method we had to set bookmarks
before is not particularly bad
well I think that there are two
situations one is kind of like the
bookmarks where you just manually set
the controls to something and then you
go and bookmark
sometimes you want a little bit more
precision and you want to actually set
them
you know to very precise values because
it's a it's a it's a real experiment
that you want to perform
yeah and then a programmatic setting is
better
okay but I want to talk about the whole
workflow that ends with a video with
with voiceover
okay
well um
so I mean because that's going to have
to be so I think llm is an alternate
you know
um
I think that that's another path I don't
think it's the only path and it's no
it's not the only path but I mean one
could imagine things like
uh here's a here's the code for
manipulate one could imagine something
where it's like okay llm here's the
stuff I want to show
you know do this and explain what's
going on
not quite possible yet but with
multimodal models something that
is definitely on its way
uh I I mean it would be bad to spend a
lot of effort designing something that
is for a world you know moments before
sort of the llms walk in
so I mean I'm just trying to understand
what
well I mean my impression of llm it's
kind of low precision and in the sense
that
that you get sort of roughly what you
say like the same thing that happens
with natural language generally sure
sure but right but but in in making you
know that's the point that in making a
video from a demonstration roughly is
already very useful yeah I think that's
useful too but I mean you know being
able to say just here's this manipulate
just make me a video of this now which
is what how many sentences do you think
let's say it had 20 controls
how many sentences do you think it takes
you to say what all the things are that
you want
I think with very high probability
that you can
give something which is you know if
you're going to explain it you're not
going to explain all 20 controls in
every part of their explanation
right
so it's going to wind up being something
that is uh
you know where you say I want to go to
this limit and that limit and then it's
got to figure out how to settle the
extra controls and I think it has a
reasonable chance of being able to do
that
um
so I mean
let's let me understand what what okay
for this this looks rather uncooked so
far yes well unfortunately
okay
but so I want to point out that one of
the main things that we were
planning and to support how this works
is
uh updates to The Bookmark system within
manipulate because the specification of
these keyframes syntactically needs to
live within manipulate
um and I think Shadi has in the in the
design notebook mentions a Time marks
page which is a proposal for an update
well let's see how it works right now
yeah
so okay where is the bookmarks option
right now that side there bookmarks okay
bookmark settings
and it has it has several limitations
that that's what okay we're not going to
redo it just because it has limitations
we're going to first understand it yep
okay
which performed those actions
I see so it's a essentially procedural
a bookmark as a function to run
these are named functions that you're
running no it's an expression
you're right you're right you're right
this was obviously done before we had
associations
correct
I mean it's yeah I don't think it needed
to use assignments to do it I don't know
why it did that but it was slippery to
manipulate
well
okay
so what's your idea for how to do it no
no I I'm not I don't I didn't
particularly want to redo it bookmarks
are bookmarks but I think it was a bad
idea to post assignments okay but wait
no no no no Roger Roger We're not gonna
do this thing about introducing another
name for something which is incredibly
similar no no okay so so what is this
now
so this is a proposal for an evolution
you need to store different data you
need to know at what time something
happens
yes okay so so this is why Lou is here
and uh discussing with him there were
several possibilities adding an
additional option as you said it is
something that is very similar to
bookmarks or obsoleting the bookmarks
name updating its name and adding new
syntaxes while maintaining but basically
what you're saying is
you can give a proposed time for The
Bookmark I mean the time might be -7 and
then you know absent time travel you
can't get there correct
right so
uh you know the times
is a crucial element like when no no I I
understand that but I'm trying to
understand in the case of a tour video
for example or an animation video let me
let me remind myself how animation video
works
um animation video is just a single
variable manipulate essentially
okay but but doesn't it have
okay how how does in the case of tour
video for example how does it
doesn't it have a way of saying that
yeah t t i step I absolutely
okay so one model that we have
step step by times TI
and unfortunately this is not
particularly viable for us given the
fact that we use Expressions to specify
these key scenes in manipulate I don't
know
wait wait wait wait wait in this case
this thing here
is a tour video
with in this case two
elements there and it's going to go
between those two God I hate the way
that this is done with the I and so on
but anyway never mind that okay uh
that's a relatively large image
okay but but so why are there no
you can specify the times or you can
leave them to be automatically computed
and in fact if you open up this is a
very silly way to say this if I might
say so I mean isn't this
what is this doing
how does it
integrate this
what is it doing
it goes between two rectangles
and this is the alternative form
yes correct where you could specify a
time as well if you added a Time key as
well I don't think it could be called
steps I think it should be called
something like
uh frame one frame two or something
okay
something like that step seems just
super confusing
I see that essentially at steps I mean
it's just not that doesn't mean anything
but generates a video by what the heck
does this mean by taking certain
by visiting certain frames within
Graphics or something
yeah
it's poorly written we should yeah okay
all right okay fine but
but here
how does this relate to the manipulate
syntax so this is this is saying at time
TI
you get frame frame I so to speak right
okay
so now in the case of manipulate
What's Happening Here is the the kind of
the knitting of the frame specification
with the original graphics
is
anything I don't fully understand it's
essentially a show what what really is
it what what is the function that is
applied
to the graphics so if you're going to
have yeah so if you're going to have the
camera
B1 rectangle
and now you're going to move to a
different rectangle and that might mean
just translation or it means translation
and rotation basically
and so you need to interpolate both of
those when you go but you're explaining
a different thing that I'm asking what
I'm asking is when you get to that frame
when you get to that time
what you have is some kind of image trim
or something
of the image so what is it exactly it
depends on the data if it is a graphics
it's some variation of uh show with a
specific plot range what is it with an
image
as some variation of image stream and
image rotate
it's kind of unfortunate that there
isn't a single function that we can say
you know take this cookie part cookie
cutter you know cut out take this cut
out in this Graphics or image
that's fair and including rotationals is
a non-trivial part as well no no I
understand it's algorithmically
non-trivial I'm I'm just saying that
yeah I'm just saying if if a new
function were to exist I feel like
including the rotations would be
important yeah it's like image cut out
or something
sure
or image I think we should have such a
function and we should know that what
the tour does is it applies to that
first thing
a so I mean the the generalized version
of that would be
um
and even this is very confusing to me
does it need to know beyond the
keyframes
it needs to know that those keyframes I
mean it's using the actual internal
information about the frame
specifications to do the touring is that
correct yeah
yeah okay so it takes apart
um so it gives you as a user you kind of
get like a relatively minimal spec
I'm saying yeah
but still very relatively precise
right but so we couldn't have a
generalized you know function video
that takes you have one and you hate it
and we all hate it what is it Developers
video generator
yeah
okay it's very generalized okay what's
the thing for so to the point that is
very hard to use
but very nice to control I mean I
understand
okay
why is this slideshow video not doing
its times in the same way that this does
it's a good question
it has go back to it again
I mean I think this is a mistake
what yeah I think that is that was a
mistake in hindsight yep which was a
mistake
well one of the two I'm not entirely
sure well I think this one for
slideshows is is useful I don't want to
be Computing you know I want to be don't
want to be doing arithmetic and I slip a
new slide in I don't want to be
re-arithmetizing everything
yeah so this this kind of has
this is okay so this is like a different
right because these are not time stamps
these are durations
well I understand that but I mean the
question is
configurations well because in the other
cases it's it's you're not going to
linger on a controlled spec you're going
to be moving all the time
so you you specify the events
rather than the
um here in a slidesh you're gonna linger
for a long time and then switch very
quickly to the next one
into our video we have dual time as well
okay but apart yeah but that that comes
in the more complicated Association
syntax of steps or frames
um
uh
just a minute
okay I'm sorry back to another
little emergency going on okay so that
back to this excuse me
uh
okay so sorry what did you just say I I
missed that the move is the point for
the other ones okay we just have
snapshots where you stop okay here
dwelling is the is the main activity
okay so that's not silly okay let's talk
about manipulate
okay so we want a way
and what are you proposing
um so so one thing that I want to make
clear is that all of these key scenes
need to be specified within the
manipulate expression uh because the
scoping
uh wouldn't allow you to specify them
given that you have an expression that
sets the variables of the manipulate
right what is the setting here is this
an expression x equals this is this
works like bookmarks it's just an
expression no no no no no no no that's
not how bookmarks Works bookmarks as we
just saw has an actual yeah an
expression which does an assignment is
that what we're doing here as well the
same because we're we're kind of
updating the framework that bookmarks is
using and yeah but I don't like this I
don't like having two names here I don't
like this yes so the other alternative
that would be to just upgrade bookmarks
and upgrades as well okay let's look at
how bookmarks Works yes
so the updated page addresses the
limitations that we think are important
for video creation okay we're fun but I
mean what we have here is a label and an
action for bookmarks
okay
no no we're not gonna do this no Roger I
think you haven't committed your update
from this yeah we just yeah we removed
this this morning and I removed it
okay all right okay fine
didn't I commit it oh whatever
so one one useful thing we were talking
is that if bookmarks have labels maybe
time marks or whatever function could be
an option of the video generation
function
and then we can refer to times goes to
labels in a sense saying that I want to
be at that setting at time five yeah
that's what we suggested to this morning
so at the right hand side could be a
label string label basically
alternatively
in bookmarks those could be annotated
with their times
I mean or the label if it's a number
maybe that's not a good idea could
represent a time that that is I feel
like that this time marks page could
just that functionality could be
included within the bookmarks option if
you look at the syntax well I mean it
depends on what okay look let's talk
about how this is in practice done yes
the
you know it doesn't really matter a lot
how
elaborated the syntax says if it's all
going to be done through a GUI anyway
yes this is what I'm I'm counting on as
well we just need an internal method of
storing this information and producing
the video but I agree in input form for
all of this the most practical one for
sure will be the the good related one
wait a minute I'm having a big Deja Vu
from like 15 years ago
um
what
is this Lou help me out there's some
Dynamic refresh something another thing
where we also have
what the heck is it it's some there's
some control or something where we also
have some kind of time marks
help me out what what am I thinking of
uh with that description I don't yet
know
okay are you talking about animator
things like animator
because animator
has the same
is it animator or is it something is
there some analog of animator that runs
to keyframe marks
to understand what I'm saying I mean
there isn't in manipulate you can
animate between buttons already
I understand I understand but there's
isn't there something here that does
this
Lou help me I'm not sure what this is
what this is is something that has times
and settings
okay
um so look at the rough page for slider
there is one calling signature for
slider that lets you specify values and
the interval of relative widths the last
Clause there
perhaps that's what you're no it's not
what I mean it's something Dynamic that
we did about 15 years ago okay I don't
remember I I don't know okay um because
because it's something related to
animator manipulator something like that
um
where we've got the same idea of having
uh
you know a time mark
I mean also we've got you know the model
that we have in uh sound note
and sound there's another thing a bit
like this where we have these symbolic
objects that represent a note that
should be played for a certain time
which is a different thing than we have
here you know the analog of a sound note
approach to this would be a
you know some kind of video frame rapper
and then a a
an overall rapper that says interpolate
between these frames
am I making sense but maybe that's not
possible because like in the case of
tour video you have to know what the
underlying graphic is that you're
walking around it's not just a question
of interpolating between the frames it's
a question of knowing that the the
underlying mechanism with the same and
manipulate
yes
I mean manipulate is simpler because it
doesn't have very Advanced controls
right
like when we come to 3D Graphics we're
going to have to interpolate 3D
rotations it's okay we have what we need
for that but those are kinds of things
one has to do
right Stephen are you thinking of the
auto run sequencing option
perhaps I am yes let me look it up
yeah
no it's the auto run not to bookmarks
yep
yes I may very well be thinking of this
I mean I remember that we we discussed a
lot
sort of an early version of Dimension
reduction here because what you've got
to do is you've got this High
dimensional space and you're going to
find this sort of space filling curve
oh it wasn't too bad on my 15 years
give or take
um
okay in any case yes this is what I was
thinking of
so explain the relationship between this
and what you're now proposing for
manipulate
so this doesn't have any concept of
frames this just when they say run
variable I it just means explore the
whole domain
okay this is very different in terms of
what happens at a specified time and
this is why this can specify durations
rather than specific types right
it says run variable I 30 seconds which
is not what the bookmarks thingy
whatever that will end up being called
um so it's a lot related but definitely
not the same thing
okay this is more automated animation
and and what we're proposing is give
control to the user on video generation
rather than
all right let's talk about the workflow
yes
then so
I'm not sure Roger if you want to go
ahead and and do that or if you want me
to
I I was I was trying to Define this okay
so I'm going to go to a random
demonstration and I want to
uh basically make my
animated version
and what you're proposing is
that I could give a script exactly I
even have a mock-up where I did it okay
but so so where there's also an audio
or a I mean where you either give a
closed caption or you give audio or both
and maybe the duration is the length of
the speech synthesize of the audio
I think that
I don't think everything needs audio but
yes we could think of that too right
let's talk through that that workflow
because
audio makes it sort of tied to a
particular language
yeah yeah but okay fine but we're going
to need explanations so sure you know we
can have those explanations as as you
know captions on top of the thing and
then those can be translated in
different languages
Etc I know that you say it we actually
do have
um in our video codecs
we have subtitles
okay in different languages right yeah
they have a language tag yes it could be
in different languages right yeah right
right I mean it's taggable for different
languages
um
and presumably you can switch on the
subtitles
uh
yeah so I mean we could have a a voice
over and then subtitles But but so
here's the way I would think about the
workflow Maybe
okay
so one possibility is speech synthesize
which you know today is still a bit
clunky just in the world and at large
although it's getting better and
probably this year one will see very
realistic You Know audio synthesis
um
and the alternative would be that you
essentially record the voiceover by
doing the following where it says uh you
know where it prompts you for example we
have some function
maybe in the function repository where
you know it goes through it shows you to
manipulate it says it says here's the
next you know Waypoint you've defined
now press record to audio capture the
thing that is going to go between this
Waypoint and this Waypoint then it takes
that audio it knows how about the
duration of the audio is it fills that
in and it puts in that voiceover
does that make sense
yep
I mean maybe well actually I I said that
a little wrong because what you want is
at a given Waypoint you're going to
dwell on that Waypoint probably
but you might want something that both
as the dwelled you know the dwell audio
and the Motion Audio
which is what I'm saying
and you could also have an audio that
spans a dwell and a piece of motion
am I making sense
yeah
I think it's important that there is
like a minimal version that doesn't do
that but optionally if one specified is
it's it's it's it also has a very stable
workflow just like you described I think
that
to make this really useful I think it
has to be annotated
you know I just don't think it's going
to be that useful to just see the the
thing sort of jump around from here to
there without explanation
well you may be right
but I think annotations can also be
textual doesn't necessarily mean
there's three options here
four options no annotations annotations
that are burnt into the video as a kind
of an overlay right which also will be
useful
yeah and which we can also do
uh
speech synthesized speech where the
source code is purely textual I mean
that seems like it could be super useful
because you can easily edit it you can
translate it you can do all kinds of
things
the other thing that's useful is to
sometimes you want to remove the
controls
because the controls are there for a
human
yeah right right right but when you have
the video you may not you may not want
the controls there may be no reason to
show the controls but I would guess most
of the time you don't want to show the
controls yeah
uh I mean sometimes the controls may be
useful as an explanation of what's going
on right but often not
right okay so then
uh
let's see I mean but but see when we
think now you're cooking okay and now
we're starting to think of this as a
storytelling tool
and now demonstrations become can become
a storytelling tool yeah yeah right
no I agree but I mean I'm just I'm just
thinking through
you know the actual workflow so let's
just enumerate I think there are four
cases
uh you know the
no caption the burnt in caption which is
image overlaid
the
uh
the thing where the video
I I don't know how useful it is to have
it silent but closed captions
I don't think it I mean if you don't
want the the voiceover just mute the
damn thing
right but but probably the case where
you have closed captions is the case
where there was voiceover but you might
choose to mute it have a different
translation translated language for the
for the closed captions Etc
uh
okay so there's Auto generated voiceover
and there's human recorded voiceover
am I right yeah
and I mean anybody want to give their
opinion about the the quality of the
speech synthesized voiceover I mean we
can't I mean the one that we have now is
not good enough we'll come to that a
little bit later
the one we have now stock Dan sounds
robotic it's it's yeah I understand I
understand but I mean I think we all
believe that it's a it's a technology
that's going to arrive fairly soon to
have
good
um
you know yes
okay well so I'm not sure
how much of this
um
uh let me see
uh okay well I mean so so maybe this is
as far as we need to go on the design of
this right now
um there's a question from the live
stream for for the about can these video
functions accept an interpolating
function
oh I mean that is already uh a hidden
option and manipulate
um but yes that sounds like a very
useful thing to add
yeah one important thing for many
controls to make them look nice is that
you really don't want just straight
interpolation because it creates kind of
jerky yes I agree so you need kind of
like a spline you know spline fitting
thing that comes in with a nice
derivative that must be in in the world
of dollying and you know yes it is yes
yes
we're talking about manipulate
manipulate has controls of dramatically
different domains it can be discrete it
could be whatever so uh the
interpolation function needs to be
tailored to the control type and this is
some of the things there fine well then
we should have a you know
a typical control
that I would say moves quickly and then
slows down at the end and then comes to
a halt you know like exactly that's
that's that's like those spline-like
endings yeah right I mean it should be
kind of like what you what you have
become used to with a car where you have
you know where you're going at a
constant speed and then you have a
deceleration and then you come to rest
right
um
my guess is that that will feel fairly
natural
uh
okay well and yeah clearly there's a
whole bunch of work to do on sort of
curating the way that this this happened
so now the question of so there's quite
a bit of control
on
yeah I mean it's it's rather confusing
because the settings thing doesn't seem
quite right here's why
you've got two parameters X and Y
EP and the end result is at a particular
mark
x equals zero y equals 10. okay
but as you get there the x coordinate
let's say the x coordinate is discrete
let's say it's n and and X or something
the N is discrete the x is continuous
the whole process by which you slow down
and approach
you know n equals zero x equals 10 or
whatever it is
not obvious not trivial it's not a pure
end State it's not a function of state
so to speak
that path matters
and they're making sense
yeah
but I kind of think if it's discreet
then you will arrive there there's no
there's no xenos Paradox with discrete
stuff
no I understand but let's say it's X and
Y variables both continuous okay okay
you can just like you've done already
for uh is it to a video
um yes you know you can have the things
spiral into that point
right so similarly here there's no
reason that the manipulate with the two
continuous variables shouldn't be
spiraling into a certain endpoint
as opposed to just moving in XY space I
mean what determines is it moving on a
JD stick in XY space what is the
structure of x y space
Etc
am I making sense I mean I I agree with
that I think what we're aiming to
provide is a good default behavior and
if the user wants to spiral in they will
have to do something more casual I
understand but we need a specification
which allows spiraling in and what you
had defined there is something with
marks where basically you've only got
the function of State you you could
Define a spiral right you could just
Define several bookmarks along the curve
oh great but how does tour video work in
that regard
so we totally we have the option of
specifying a pure function as well and
that allows you to do this spiral let me
see
I see a function there
to generate
steps locations for each frame so that
function is fed a continuous parameter
single time parameter is that correct
yep
where is the specification for that
don't tell me it's not in here come on
guys you know the rules we can't have it
only in the examples where is it
when a step as provider is an
association of properties
okay I'm kind of annoyed we've been
through this many times
okay
yep we should add it yeah you go through
all the functions from your team and
make sure that that mistake does not
occur
please
yep
what the heck there's nothing here where
is it where's the thing specifying how
you use the function there last one
so that's just not good enough
it's just not good enough I mean I don't
know what so it just takes the time
and I don't even know the range of the I
mean the time is presumably in seconds
correct
okay
but notice that in this case
this is returning rectangles
yeah so anyway but now any of those
support that spec step specifications
okay I understand but so what that would
be in the case that you're now
describing as something which returns in
effect an assignment
am I making sense
yeah there are yeah
uh
it's a little weird that it's well I
mean you know it's such a heavyweight
thing to generate a video frame but
doing an assignment is peanuts
right
if that's how we want to do it with an
assignment which we may have no choice
about
foreign
I feel like I'm not sure
than uh the manipulative video would be
the the best tool for that rather than
just using animation video with that
single variable time and then just
making sure that that time is used in
the expression that generates the frame
yeah but but no you you can't get away
with that because it could be the case
that in this story
right you're going from here to there to
there to there and then you spiral in on
something else okay in that case yes
okay fine
um
now just so I understand it
you know we need a full workflow where
the thing has a titling slide you know
where you do a slideshow video of a
manipulate video and of a slide and then
a manipulate video and then there's
something else will that work
I mean we do have functionality to
combine with this no no no that's not
what I'm asking for I'm asking to use
the slideshow video mechanism so that
you can put up well maybe maybe I'm
maybe you're right that's a good idea
adding slideshow video adding video
support for those inputs right but I
mean you know you might also be right
that if all that we want to do is just
take a slide for a certain time from a
slideshow video and then Ram it into a
manipulate video because after all it's
although you might want dissolves and
all kinds of things like this
but
you know I think when when movies are
made right it's like
you know they have this idea of a shot
you know like like a movie consists of
you know 1500 shots or something
and each one I guess the camera can move
around during it but it's kind of each
one is a kind of a setup and then you do
your thing there if I'm understanding
correctly
that's kind of how we've been that's
kind of why I've been thinking about
this in terms of these
um creators
um that we have certain kinds of
mechanisms and now we build easy
mechanisms to do those shots if you like
right but then the combining of the
shots is just a video join is that
correct yeah
okay
well that's not unreasonable
and then
but one thing that I think is a little
complicated there in video join is
voiceover
yes because you might want the voiceover
to span
multiple shots
I mean I think in in typical movies
right doesn't the music track you know
it's it's
the music is continuous even as the
you're going from shot to shot yep
and I think it's very common to create
the audio track separately
um but I believe we have to go back to
our audio track injection uh subtitle
track injection at specific times and
make that a little more seamless so I
mean maybe we need in this meeting maybe
we need some of our people from the
video team who know how typical video
editing software works and so on and
maybe we have that here do we have that
here do you go you guys know that well
or not
I don't know I do no okay fine I've
talked to our video people though a
couple of times well why don't we have
them in the next one of these meetings
sure
um
and suggest that they could watch part
of this meeting
recording to get up to speed
uh I think what this enables the kinds
of things that we're building now are
videos that we would never build before
or we would have to be strongly strongly
strongly motivated oh sure I agree
completely but I mean what I'm asking
for is you know as I understand it when
people make a you know a movie or
something they you know they're
literally the you know the orchestra is
playing in front of a you know no I mean
we should think about it but I'm just
trying to explain when you know I think
that you know the way it works is you
have the Silent Video and then you
literally have the you know then then
people know these are the time marks you
have to hit
in the thing you're playing when you you
know when the grand you know you know
the grand symbol you know thing happens
and the you know has to be when the
video does this
so in other words I think people think
of it as you make the video and then you
add a soundtrack to it
but I don't know you know in our case
where it's explanatory video I think our
video team doesn't add soundtrack I mean
we we don't compose our own music
um no no but we do put music beds on
videos but but that's mostly music type
music as in it's not it's kind of rare
well we should've done it we've
certainly done that we've said that's
true we have done it but it's kind of
rare if you I I know but we're not that
that music isn't well coordinated with
the video because to do that you really
have to have you know all kinds of fancy
work done right which we've not been
doing but so in this case the problem is
that we want to make it easy for the
particular case we're dealing with here
to add you know voice over that is
somehow coordinated with what's going on
um
okay uh all right we should wrap up
fairly soon here but let's take a little
look forward so I think there's more to
think about here another meeting for
this with with video folk and so on now
let's just take a quick look here
okay that's nice so you can say an image
of a graphic with with what kinds of
options to the graphics does does pixel
constrained work for example
and those pixel constrained work
I haven't looked into that specifically
I think you should what other options
absolutely I'm sorry pixel constraint is
documented to be obsolete what's it what
really because people use it all the
time
really
well I would talk to Jeremy Davis about
this because he uses it all the time
okay
in fact pretty much anybody who does
stuff with like cellular automaton
images uses it yep
so something is not working that's
causing that to be necessary
I don't know if it's an anti-aliasing
issue or what
okay anyway that's the thing to explore
but what did you have in mind here now
except most Graphics options thanks the
few options that I documented that I
found them missing things like frame
grid lines
um
you mean if you say image of the
graphics it just drops those features of
the graph no no no no no no so image
image object itself can have all of
those Graphics options now you can
construct an image oh that's nice okay
yeah so the key use case is that various
workflows like medical or our own
highlight image ads and annotations
basically
and now it becomes a non-image
and in the future they can can still be
images so you're saying frame Arrow true
correct
oh actually that's a framed owl
special species right
well in some cases frames are good like
if the tumor is you know two centimeters
this is already a circle 0.1 centimeters
because this is in pixels right yes
that's already useful
great
and epilogue is surely useful right yep
I mean if I say epilogue
Arrow you know disk
a hundred
comma 80 comma
20 or something
that's lovely
very nice
and and presumably
I can do picture in picture by putting
another owl there
I'd have to do an inset presumably
yes right yes
okay all right that's good make sure you
show an example with an inset I'll do
inset yeah
the find image shapes
they're using Christopher's um
uh Library mechanism or is this actually
burnt in code
no no Christopher no that that
um still is not working with most
libraries
this is building this is separate code
well what's not working this is
Christopher's code we checked it in fact
for a very simple Library
um early I hope you complained yes okay
fine what's not working about it we send
a whole list I can okay all right fine
okay fine okay
and trust it but roughly what's what's
not working about it
um some special C plus plus
oh yeah right it was it's for c yeah
right the stuff he built is primarily
for C yep
right okay so that's a that's that's the
issue there
okay find image shapes let's take a look
at that that sounds interesting
sounds a bit like image graphics
wait a minute is this image Graphics
just with
I'm confused here
it's
it's recognizing simple geometric shapes
within images
right so it's a sub part of image
Graphics which would try to turn the
whole image into shapes yes
image Graphics is is no I mean image
Graphics is very general in terms of
you know what it does these are for
simple shapes no no I I got it but this
is image Graphics would presumably
include all these shapes and many others
for an for an image is that correct
correct currently we only have anything
that is a contour so lines circles and
so forth but then
I think this is a filtered version of
image Graphics true or not true not true
oh great could be seen as that Roger
though
sort of but I think you're both missing
the point so
so this one is to recognize regular
simple shapes within images I get that
image Graphics is basically vectorizing
our graphics and so it's running
marching cubes to recognize borders and
it has nothing to do whether shapes are
simple or not
I see what you're saying I see what
you're saying so so this is
attempting I mean this is essentially a
model you're saying image Graphics that
they're two different models being used
this one the model is
you know has an emphasis on low numbers
of parameters in the in the in the model
whereas the other one probably has an
emphasis on fidelity
yeah you're right that's that's the way
to see it too yep yeah so you could say
that image graphics and it literally
turns it into graphics
is is
um
it's like a non-parametric model I don't
know why people call it that because
they have massive numbers of parameters
I know but I know what you mean
yeah right
okay I understand so this is essentially
a fit here yes fitting lines too
the two key features in the image yeah
in some simple shapes occur a lot in in
in the man-made world
I mean if I take this image here for
example
which is not so man-made
I know if I say find image we don't have
it we don't have it in today's prototype
yeah okay but but in principle if I said
disc here it would yeah and I would
suggest strongly that you do that
and I would even suggest in the world of
the future
that you allow things like disk
underscore Radius 2 or something
or is that crazy
I proposed similar things and we did
similar things for distributions it's
incredibly costly to do
but still as a design it's you know it's
a nice design but as exponentially numb
in the case of image what should I do
with color styling and all of that
well this one doesn't make a statement
about that
right right but you're saying find the
red disc or something
no no no this is this is working on
um
a grayscale image where whatever kind of
a shape you want to find is highlighted
so for today
it would just be this
but in the future it might be a pattern
that involves you know color distance
and all kinds of stuff
okay it might be you know find a disk
radius less than two radius greater than
two for example that might be a very
common thing to want to do right
say here we want you know
blank
uh question mark hash greater than two
makes sense it'd be very cool to be able
to do that I mean actually so here's
that would be really difficult but well
I just realized the way that we can do
it it's Brute Force but it's kind of in
the spirit of what Stephen is saying
like our cases you know our pattern
matcher is kind of stupid it just looks
at everything and then filters out yeah
let's say that this one did the same
thing it found all the disks and then
just filtered out then then code wise it
wouldn't explode at all actually right
right right that's what I would suggest
okay that's how we were thinking about
it right and then then we could also do
something like and so then in a way what
you're proposing is the same as just
like getting at all the output and then
running case you know cases exactly just
a a way of um
uh so here it will be color distance you
know
hash comma red
lesson I don't know if we looked at
color distance it's black and white
what do you mean well
by the way did that semicolon did that
ampersand
oh before it goes in the wrong place
okay never mind
um
okay
uh
all right
anyway I mean that this seems like a
nice very nice conceptual syntax so to
speak
yep so in some sense
this is almost like I mean we've got
image cases
which is a little different
but this is more of a cases kind of well
what does it return as output
a bunch of lines circles discs
eventually
okay so it's the it's the Primitives
it's The Primitives and then you can get
properties for what has what has been
detected like proposition color
if it was a style you could potentially
pull up that
or are you just dealing with geometry
currently we were just thinking geometry
I'll I'll have to see if we can really
squeeze in style subsets as well in
there
no I I know that and what I I think as
long as we call it find image shapes it
can just be geometries or shapes and
then find image subsets or something
like that
cases right right I understand relate to
the image
that's a image cases is a higher level
construct I think we're looking at more
classical template matching pattern
matching if if we talk about something
like find sub images
maybe maybe not we also have that I'll
have I'll have to look into that think
about it more okay fine this is just
shapes no color for that
okay
that's nice so the text recognized is
going to get better basically yes
oh we've got an audio page
yeah audio GUI is getting updated if you
want to open that subject foreign
subsequence of um
section yeah that one yeah see
okay what's the this is the before this
is the after yeah yeah and the
comparison with the video GUI controls
which is done
which is down below yeah
that's too big that font is too big
that font should be this kind of size
I agree
yeah that's the mistake
make sense you also have the eyes of a
hawk
what funky
what I font pies
um
and what about the icons
which I think is someone else
what's that those are dropped that we
don't have them in the new version
is that globally true for for how we're
doing the the data in whatever stuff
I guess so
I think they're accustomed
uh icons in any other thing I can be
present in the store in notebook or
restore change storage location button
the one on the lower right
that opens up a menu and okay but the
the current state is not indicated by an
icon correct
okay
so rather than the waveform you want to
go to this kind of thing
yes that is not the curve that is the
depiction of the full waveform rather
than the previous one that just gives
you the way from at a specific time
like are they I know I have no opinion
about this so that that's the amplitude
of the waveform yeah this gives you a
better way to differentiate between
audio files well the previous one was
useless and less well let's use that
looks very much like SoundCloud
correct it's nice
but is is that
again my naivete and lack of cultural
knowledge I mean in the case of
something like SoundCloud is that
showing audio as a function of time or
is that showing what used to be showing
on like
stereo things were maybe no no
it's the way for it's the way it just
lights up it's as it plays you can see
it sort of turns its color as you
progress along the waveform I see that's
it and we do that too
yes yes
okay
all right we should wrap here but this
is nice stuff and clearly this is not
the last meeting about this um
oh my gosh
seriously we've got a chest playing
system now yeah
okay why not I guess it's part of the
human condition so to speak it's bother
I mean it feels like
if we're doing that
yeah I mean it's an interesting prong
let's say
that's exactly how I think about it
I mean it's an indication
to me
this is It's driven by great enthusiasm
sustainable a few of our developers okay
fine but but but so one thing to think
about there you know we've got I would
say pure Force Witnesses
not relevant for S but there's the whole
game theory what has happened to the
game theory project by the way anything
at the moment
Bluff we that there's nothing to if you
ask there's nothing to send out if so
you know because there's no we need we
need to
start over
the solid the foundations of it is okay
but the code sucks
okay
be a good thing to get done
um but that's very different from
actually no I I know that I know that
the thing that this reminds me maybe a
little bit more of is the virtual
machine framework
which also is partially done
I'm not sure
does that does that resin I mean does
that analogy make sense to you Roger
um
I think that this is a little bit well
this is too specialized
virtual machines could be very
specialized too
well I mean you're poking at a device a
thing
but but isn't a virtual machine like a
whole architecture it supports It's
usually the case well it could be a
cellular automata it could be a
registered machine it could be something
quite idealized and simple
oh okay
so
is it I mean I don't know what use cases
you guys went after when you was sort of
doing that but one thing is sort of
assuring machines to you know IBM 1790s
to
uh early video games
okay I was going to get to video games
was that kind of part of it yes
all right go ahead you're gonna say one
more thing no no it's a longer
discussion I have a bunch of things to
say but I it's like I don't wanna that's
right okay
sounds good lots of stuff happening here
right we'll need another one in this
series obviously another medium
Mysteries okay thanks a lot guys thank
you